could we understand you have roughly
ninety three thousand or so from your
amazing Kickstarter campaign for
manchild after you know fees taxes and
whatnot in the bank yet you've been very
transparent and said that this is not
currently enough for you to make the
first feature film to the level that you
want to make it do you feel that maybe
manchild is too ambitious of a first
feature well it's certainly an ambitious
first feature you know I think the jury
is out and whether it's too ambitious
you know there are a couple things going
on with the project other than you know
constantly working on and trying to get
it made and I think one of the
challenges is that no matter even if you
run a filmmaking website as I do and you
know I won my first filmmaking award 12
years ago so I've been you know pursuing
this for a while but you're always
learning things and they're always
things you didn't know what you started
it and you know as somebody who's done a
lot DIY productions where not only was I
doing a lot of the craft elements as far
as being a DP and being editor and being
the sound guy and being the after
effects artist and everything this stuff
that I've done has also been
logistically very contained so you know
the west side that wet my web series yes
we're out on the streets we're walking
down the street with no permits and we
didn't have insurance and you know we
were literally breaking into crack
houses and climb me across roofs and
just you know there are things that you
hey you don't want to do repeatedly for
your own health and for the safety of
your actors and performers be there
illegal and you know see you definitely
want to do these things with child
actors so I think you know I was
certainly a bit naive as far as how far
I thought I could stretch a dollar on a
real production where people are insured
and whether where you're paying for
locations and where you're doing things
you know not in a luxury way not with
trailers not with you know spending a
lot of money that doesn't need to be
spent which is the basics
having permits and having insurance and
making sure that you know the child
actors are going to be protected or the
adults if someone gets hurt you know
we're filming a sports movie and so once
I was meeting with producers there are
course producers who are going to push
this to be something that you don't want
to make it and that's a challenge and
I'm you know we're not looking to make
this into the blind side you know or
Rudy or some some one of these larger
sports movies that you're you're used to
thinking of as a sports movie but there
are just it's an educational process to
look at a real budget and to say oh okay
you know where all the ways that we can
trim money and then you get to a point
where the movie you wrote is going to be
best served by a minimum budget level
and that just wasn't you know as you
said we have 93,000 in the bank and
that's even after we made this short you
know we haven't touched a penny of that
and there's nothing wrong with wanting
what's best for your movie and I could
go cut all of the basketball scenes from
the script and go make this movie but
they're all there for that all those
things are there for a reason and so for
me you know regardless of what the
external understanding of what I'm going
through is at the end of the day I exist
to make this film the best that could
possibly be and you know I'm going to
knock down walls and I'm gonna you know
take some comments of people you know
either misconstruing what I'm doing or
just feeling like I'm you know
abandoning the DIY ethos but ultimately
you know you want what's best for your
film and I think if you look at most
Kickstarter projects very few of those
their entire budget was raised through
Kickstarter and all my Kickstarter page
I say very clearly you can go back and
look at it because kick starter locs
your page after your campaigns over and
you can't change a word that I say I'm
looking for a producer on one side with
producers we're going to do a real
budget and then we're going
have some hard decisions to make about
whether we cut things from the script or
need to raise more money or need to do
both so I think the jury is out on we're
in between those different options we're
going to end up but you know no one said
this is going to be easy and at the end
of the day if it takes me longer to make
the film that I wanted to but I make the
movie that I wanted to you know I'll
take that delay instead of sort of
trimming and cutting and turning us into
something that wasn't what I wanted to
make in the first place
you